utile qui misent toujours sur la
stratégie vaccinale depuis hier la
troisième dose est obligatoire pour les
soignants et les pompiers rappel
vaccinal pas forcément suivi comme
espéré par le gouvernement pour le reste
de la population à voir tout cela avec
notre reporter guilmard aussi
[Musique]
guillemat bonjour alors une actualité
sanité encore chargé en fin de semaine
dernière et des français qui vont devoir
faire leurs rappels plus rapidement que
prévu
et oui tout à fait olivier vous avez
raison alors tout d'abord il y a les
soignants alors rappelez vous les
professionnels de santé avait fait
l'objet d'une obligation vaccinale pour
pouvoir continuer à exercer après le 15
octobre dernier est bien rebelote
olivier véran l'avait annoncé
mi-décembre les soignants et les
pompiers avaient jusqu'à ce dimanche
hier pour effectuer leurs rappels de
vaccination sous peine d'être suspendu
sans salaire alors à priori le mouvement
semble plutôt bien entamé puisque selon
santé publique france par exemple plus
des trois quarts des salariés des
hôpitaux et des cliniques éligible à un
rappel avait reçu ont déjà reçu leur
troisième injection et bien sûr peuvent
continuer à exercer ce qu'ils ont reçu
leur deuxième dose ou sont tombées
malades il ya moins de sept mois sauf
que cette règle 17 mois dont je ne vous
parle est bien elle va changer au 15
février prochain et pas que pour les
soignants d'ailleurs pour toute la
population concrètement le pass
vaccinale sera désormais valide non plus
7 mai quatre mois après une injection ou
une comptine à une contamination au sort
ce kof 2 c'est cette nouvelle règle que
le ministre de la santé a expliqué dans
une vidéo postée sur twitter il ya
quelques jours regardez 7 millions
d'entre vous n'ont pas encore fait leur
rappel si c'est votre cas c'est à vous
particulièrement que je m'adresse
jusqu'ici c'était sept mois après la
dernière injection pour conserver son
pass à partir du 15 février ce sera
quatre mois après la dernière injection
de façon pratique ça veut dire que si
vous avez eu votre dernière injection
avant le 15 octobre au 15 février si
vous n'avez pas fait votre rappel votre
pass ne sera plus actif si vous êtes
confirmé pour la cause vide vous ne
pouvez pas vous faire vacciner tout de
suite mais vous aurez un certificat de
rétablissement qui sera valable pour une
durée de quatre mois
il m'a ya aussi les annonces sur la fin
du masque à l'école alors les enfants
est-ce qu'ils vont bientôt pouvoir
l'enlever ce masque
est oui a priori un olivier en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a laissé entendre jean
michel blanquer r il pourrait y avoir un
allègement des mesures sanitaires à
l'école au retour des vacances de
février jeudi pourrait qu'il n'y a aucun
calendrier précis avancer ni même de
seuil épidémique en deçà duquel les
enfants pourront enlever leurs masques
en salle de classe en tout cas d'ici la
fin de l'année scolaire a déclaré jean
michel blanquer air sur france 2 il hier
donc la fin du masque à l'école entre
fin février et fin juin ce qui laisse
une marge confortable au gouvernement
pour s'adapter
merci beaucoup guilmain pour cette
précision qu'il marosi en direct devant
le ministère de la santé à paris